Yeah
info ben
I thought you were hiding something, but I thought a
stray dog ​​wouldn't help me, right?
[music]
Come back and let me fly It
's been selfish of me from the beginning Teleportation can interfere with predictions, but it doesn't necessarily
change the future for the better
I can't be a victim This time, the scale is different from the women I've seen so far It's
selfish that you cut yourself down to save your dog It
's selfish that I won't back down here
Good,
I'm dragging my feet and running away from scratch ana I'm
glad
I was let down, and I'm justice for my family.
Oh
yes
, there's no doubt that it's this child, isn't it?
But you shouldn't show your tears that easily, it's a
lie,
everyone